partiamo con un piccolo esercizio
mettetevi comodi prendete un bel respiro
e chiudete gli occhi
immaginate di essere fermi al semaforo
di una città
intorno a voi prevalgono il grigio
l'asfalto le luci artificiali e i rumori
del traffico
state respirando ma sentite solo odore
di smog
ora
provate ad immaginare di essere in un
bosco
e vide di trovarvi davanti al ruscello
che lo attraversa
e di ascoltare il canto degli uccelli
che lo abitano
prendete un bel respiro della sua area
ricca di ossigeno e profumata di pino
muschio e fiori
e lentamente
tornate qui riaprendo gli occhi
come vi siete sentiti quando eravate in
città
come vi siete sentiti invece quando
eravate nel bosco
la relazione umana con l'ambiente è una
costante della nostra vita e determina
in modo radicale le nostre funzioni
corporee le nostre emozioni i nostri
pensieri ma anche i nostri comportamenti
per illustrare la profonda inter
relazione umana con l'ambiente vi
racconterò la storia della malattia
tropicale che mi ha colpita nel 2017
quando vivevo a bali in indonesia
lì lavorava green school una scuola
meravigliosa completamente costruita in
bambù dove le aule non hanno mura e il
cortile è la giungla circostante qui
educava moiz giovane gray leader del
futuro ad entrare in azione per generare
un impatto positivo per il pianeta e
facevamo completamente con sé nella
natura rendendo le montagne l'oceano e
il cielo le nostre aule all'aperto sì
perché se vogliamo che l'amore per la
natura fiorisca questo va stimolato ed
educato sin dall'infanzia
improvvisamente sono stata colpita da
una malattia che per più di un mese non
ha trovato una diagnosi
durante questo periodo ho vissuto di
tutto da febbre ininterrotta 40 gradi al
essere trasportata in un aereo ambulanza
dal mio ospedale di bali a quello di
singapore sino allo smettere
completamente di camminare e di trovarmi
in quel famoso tunnel di luce di passa
al dall'aldilà
dopo un mese finalmente i medici hanno
scoperto cosa avessi il mio corpo era
stato preso d'assedio
un parassita tropicale l'ameba esto
litica un essere che si era moltiplicato
nel mio ambiente corporeo risucchiando
né tutte le risorse
ma che senso aveva tutto questo durante
la mia malattia ho fatto due scoperte
che ne hanno cambiato completamente il
corso e poi la mia vita
1 so che è dentro e anche fuori
ho capito che i luoghi in cui viviamo
riflettono chi siamo
per esempio avete mai pensato perché
abbiamo bisogno di creare e di sentirci
a casa
siamo degli esseri fisici che vivono un
ambiente fisico e la casa è quel luogo
dove la nostra psiche sente di aver
trovato il proprio contenitore e
soddisfa il bisogno psicologico di
ancorare la nostra identità
così per tre mesi ho deciso di fare
della mia stanza d'ospedale la mia casa
riempiendo la con tutti quegli elementi
che mi ricordavano i miei valori e amori
più autentici come quello per la natura
che sin da piccola riesce a farmi
superare le difficoltà della vita così
come è stato anche questa volta
2 ciò che è fuori è anche dentro
ho avuto la fortuna di venire
ospedalizzata a singapore riconosciuta
in tutto il mondo per saper offrire ai
pazienti numerose opportunità di entrare
in contatto con la natura dall ampia
finestra della mia stanza d'ospedale
regnava la luce del sole tutto il giorno
materiali e aromi naturali erano
distribuiti in tutto l'edificio così
come piante terrazzi giardini con pesci
e uccelli
questo approccio l'ospedalizzazione è
basato sui primi studi pioneristici di
psicologia ambientale che dimostrarono
che dopo un intervento chirurgico
importante i pazienti guariscono più
rapidamente quando esposti alla natura
così per esempio la possibilità per me
di vedere delle piante aumentava la
velocità della mia guarigione e
diminuiva il mio dolore
ed è per questo che è nata la psicologia
ambientale l'ambito della psicologia di
cui mi occupo che è un campo
interdisciplinare basato sull'evidenza
scientifica su come noi trasformiamo il
nostro ambiente è come il nostro
ambiente assolvo a sua volta ci
trasforma e si riflette e lo fa con lo
scopo di studiarne meccanismi per poi
promuovere il nostro benessere così come
quello dell'ambiente in cui viviamo
durante la mia malattia in particolare
ho scoperto la ricerca scientifica sulla
bio filia ma cos'è la biophilia bio vita
filia amore la biophilia il nostro
ancestrale amore per la vita e per la
natura di cui noi siamo parte il termine
è stato introdotto dallo psicanalista
erich fromm nel 64 ed è poi stato
ripreso 20 anni dopo dal biologo
evoluzionista di harward wilson
egli ha definito nel 2002 la biophilia
come la nostra tendenza innata ad essere
attratti dalle forme di vita e su tutto
ciò che le ricorda ed in alcune
circostanze di affidarvisi emotivamente
dunque la biophilia è qualcosa che
accomuna tutti noi e proteggere il
nostro bisogno e legame con la natura è
oggi la mia missione
sì perché nei nostri habitat artificiale
ormai molto lontani dalla natura in cui
il nostro cervello è stato mappato per
centinaia di migliaia di anni c'è il
rischio concreto che la biophilia non
riceva più gli stimoli adeguati quella
mancanza di connessione con la natura
svanisce generazione dopo generazione il
ricordo della natura stessa causando
fenomeni come l'amnesia ambientale
generazionale il deficit di natura ed un
intelligenza naturalistica atrofizzata
che insieme portano una società bio
fobica che quindi ha paura di altre
forme di vita e all'aggravarsi
dell'attuale degrado ambientale di cui
noi siamo responsabili
infatti la biophilia è talmente ovvia
che talvolta la dimentichiamo
durante il lock down the cove 19 abbiamo
avuto l'opportunità di sperimentare
quanto la nostra mente il nostro corpo
il nostro ambiente siano interconnessi
e voi come vi siete sentiti durante
questi mesi a casa
studi condotti durante questo periodo
mostrano che chi viveva in ambientazioni
con scarsi elementi verde qualità
dell'aria ed illuminazione naturale ha
corso un rischio due volte maggiore di
manifestare sintomi di depressione e
moderata o grave rispetto coloro che
invece godevano di questi elementi che
tuttora continuiamo a sottostimare
non a caso però in questo periodo
numerosi cittadini si sono mobilitati
creando i propri boschi verticali
allestendo finestre e terrazze e balconi
con piante e fiori generando così un
impatto positivo non solo per se stessi
ma anche per gli altri
sapete che già da prima della pandemia
spendiamo il 90 per cento del nostro
tempo in ambienti indoor ovvero chiusi
sì siamo una specie indoor
ma cosa può succedere nel lungo termine
più della metà della popolazione
mondiale vive in zone urbane e crescere
in zone urbane raddoppia il rischio di
sviluppare disturbi di salute mentale da
adulti di cui oggi soffre una persona su
quattro
così come lo stress considerato
dall'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità come l'epidemia del xxi secolo in
quanto affligge nove persone su dieci
fattori di stress ambientale come la
mancanza di natura l'asfalto il rumore
le auto e l'inquinamento atmosferico
sono insostenibili per la nostra
biologia e psicologia e causano per
esempio un aumento dei tassi di
depressione del 40 per cento e di ansia
del 20 per cento
ma quindi se riduciamo il nostro
contatto con la natura ai sempre più
scarsi momenti di tempo libero come
possiamo garantirci il necessario
contatto quotidiano con essa
e ancora se non abbiamo la possibilità
di sperimentare il piacere il benessere
e la sicurezza che la natura genera in
noi che cosa ne sarà della nostra
biophilia
quando non possiamo immergerci in natura
la natura può essere portata da noi
possiamo farlo creando degli ambienti
che vanno a stimolare la nostra
biophilia attraverso il baio feeling
design o progettazione biofisica lo
facciamo seguendo dei precisi schemi di
applicazione che risalgono alle ricerche
di steven keller professor emerito di
ecologia sociale presso yale university
e pioniere di questa scienza applicata
egli infatti ha scoperto più di 70
caratteristiche nella natura che sono
state fondamentali nel corso della
nostra evoluzione per garantire la
salute il benessere e la produttività
dei nostri antenati
oggi possiamo portare questi stessi
elementi attributi della natura
all'interno dei nostri habitat urbani
indoor artificiali per godere dei
medesimi benefici
infatti la semplice azione di vedere
odorare gustare udire o toccare la
natura innesca nel nostro cervello dopo
pochissimi secondi le cosiddette
esperienze rigenerative che sono in
grado di ricaricare le nostre energie
psico fisiche così come di ridurre lo
stress fino al 60 per cento
possiamo connetterci con la natura anche
stando in casa per esempio privilegiando
l'illuminazione e la ventilazione
naturale
così come le viste sul verde e sul cielo
scegliendo materiali aromi e colori
naturali per i nostri arredi e finiture
portando l'esterno all'interno con
profumi e suoni della natura
il baio flick design può essere portato
anche in azienda traducendosi in un
aumento della produttività della
creatività e del benessere dei
lavoratori
non a caso tra le aziende più innovative
tecnologiche al mondo hanno investito
proprio nel bajo il feeling design per
connettere i propri dipendenti alla
natura così come istituzioni educative
della portata di harvard stanford hanno
scelto il baio fili design per gli spazi
dei propri studenti aumentandone così la
velocità di apprendimento del 30 per
cento così come i risultati accademici
ma quindi se è possibile sperimentare la
biophilia stando in casa in ufficio oa
scuola
come vi sentireste se potesse godere di
questi stessi benefici semplicemente
camminando per la vostra città
alcune città hanno accolto la sfida
dell'urbanizzazione comuni invito alla
propria evoluzione naturale diventando
città più fili che
la baio filix it is network di cui io
faccio parte è una rete internazionale
di città focalizzate sull'aumento della
connessione tra persone in natura e tra
persone persone all'interno dell'abitato
urbano lo fanno in modo consapevole
ponendo la natura al centro della
propria progettazione e governance
creando opportunità per i cittadini di
conoscere e connettersi con la natura
all'interno dei propri spazi urbani
l'interazione sociale in natura a
straordinari benefici su tutta la
comunità e non è un caso che città come
singapore ed oslo dove avuto
l'opportunità di fare ricerca sono città
inclusive sicura e resilienti
quello che sentite è il paesaggio sonoro
di san francisco una delle città partner
del bar fili cities network
chissà quale sarà la prima città
biofisica d'italia magari una città che
ha ospitato sta ospitando ospiterà un
tedesco me questo
qualunque sia la risposta
il mio impegno è quello di collaborare
con gli stakeholder affinché questo
avvenga
i nostri predecessori
gli antichi romani dicevano mente sana
in un corpo sano ed è oggi comune
prenderci cura della nostra salute
fisica per tutelare quella mentale
oggi sappiamo anche che per una mente
sana è necessario un ambiente sano che
sia in grado di connetterci con la
natura se tutti abbiamo cura del nostro
ambiente
esso avrà cura di noi
ogni giorno abbiamo l'opportunità di
scegliere ciò che vogliamo vedere di più
nella nostra vita è ciò che non vogliamo
più vedere nella nostra vita e nel
nostro ambiente
il mio invito
è quello di cominciare a creare una
nuova società partendo da dentro ognuno
di noi
e di coltivare la connessione con la
natura
fuori di noi
ciò che è dentro anche fuori e ciò che è
fuori e anche dentro
[Applauso]